aquí tenemos un segundo problema del
libro estadística de ape de secado ce
punto org el cual es esencialmente un
libro de libre distribución lo estoy
usando para que practiquemos con algunos
problemas de estadística aquí tenemos el
número 2
las calificaciones semestrales de
estadística para una preparatoria se
distribuyen normalmente con una media de
81 y una desviación estándar de 6.3
calcula los puntajes z para cada una de
las siguientes calificaciones elabora y
etiqueta una gráfica para cada caso y
probablemente lo podemos hacer en la
misma gráfica pero lo primero que vamos
a hacer es recordar qué es lo que es un
puntaje z y qué es un puntaje z un
puntaje z es una medida para evaluar
cuántas desviaciones estándar ha alejado
de la media de la media así de simple
así que tenemos que calcular a cuantas
desviaciones estándar están de la media
estos amigos y ese es su puntaje z
empecemos con
el inciso a para el inciso a tenemos 65
para empezar vamos a calcular qué tan
alejado está 65 de la media voy a hacer
aquí una gráfica la cual podemos
utilizar todo el tiempo así es que esta
va a ser nuestra distribución tenemos
una media de 81 esa es nuestra media y
una desviación estándar de 6.3 nos dicen
que es una distribución normal vamos a
hacer una linda curva de campana la
correspondiente una distribución normal
aquí tenemos la mejor curva que yo soy
capaz de hacer aquí tenemos la media que
es de 81 y la desviación estándar de 6.3
vamos a tomar arriba de la media 6.3 y
6.3 por abajo de la media así que si nos
movemos 6.3 en la dirección positiva
este valor aquí va a ser 87.3 y si nos
movemos 6.3 en la dirección negativa
llegamos a
cuanto 74.7 correcto si sumamos 6
regresamos 80.7 y luego punto 3 nos va a
llevar a 81 si es que eso es una
desviación estándar abajo y arriba de la
media si agregamos dos desviaciones
estándar por arriba y por abajo y así
sucesivamente es sería la gráfica la
distribución normal calculemos entonces
los des puntajes z para cada una de
estas calificaciones empecemos con 65
qué tan lejos está 65 de la media 65 va
a estar en algún lugar por aquí lo
primero que tenemos que hacer es qué tan
lejos está así que la distancia es y
quieres que sea número positivo bueno de
hecho queremos un número negativo porque
el puntaje z va a ser positivo o
negativo negativo significa que está a
la izquierda de la media y positivo
significa que está a la derecha de la
media tenemos entonces 65 menos 81 y esa
es la distancia a la que está el valor
con respecto a la media pero lo que
queremos es tenerlo con respecto a la
desviación estándar lo dividimos
entonces entre 6.3
que es que tantas desviaciones estándar
está ese valor y esto nos va a dar igual
la verdad amos 81 - 65 esto va a ser
menos 16 sobre 6.3 sacamos nuestra
calculadora y dividimos menos 16 entre
6.3 y nos da menos 2.53 9 que ya
redondeando esto nos da aproximadamente
igual a menos 254 ese es el puntaje z
para una calificación de 65 bastante
inmediato el proceso y si sobre 83 una
calificación de 83 entonces 83 - 81 la
distancia de 83 a la media esos son dos
calificaciones por cierto aquí tenemos
el inciso al que obtuvimos que es menos
2.54 desviaciones estándar es decir aquí
tenemos una 2
y media aproximadamente aquí tenemos
entonces el inciso a entonces tenemos
aquí 83 81 dos calificaciones por arriba
de la media
lo dividimos entre la desviación
estándar que 6.3 esto nos va a dar igual
sacamos la calculadora y nos da 83 menos
81 es 2 dividido entre 6.3 esto nos da
aproximadamente igual a 0.32 punto 32
entonces 83 está a punto 32 desviaciones
estándar por arriba de la media
aproximadamente un tercio una desviación
estándar si esto es una desviación
estándar entonces estamos a punto tres
desviaciones estándar con respecto a la
media inciso c
93 hacemos lo mismo a cuánto está 93 de
la media es 93 menos 81 esto nos da
igual a 12 pero lo que haremos en
términos de desviaciones estándar
entonces 12 a cuántas direcciones
estándar arriba la media esta es va a
ser casi 2 déjame sacar la calculadora
obtenemos 12 dividido entre 6.3 es 1.9
desviaciones estándar su puntaje set es
1.9 lo que significa que está 1.9
desviaciones estándar entonces aquí
tenemos una desviación estándar y aquí
tenemos punto 9 desviaciones estándar
entonces aquí ubicaríamos una
calificación de 9.3 su puntaje set es
1.9 lo que significa que está 1.9
desviaciones estándar arriba de la media
hagamos el último
una calificación de 100 lo voy a hacer
magenta inciso de 100 bueno el mismo
procedimiento cuanto está haciendo la
media 100 menos 81 y dividido entre la
magnitud entre el valor entre la
cantidad que representa la desviación
estándar que 6.3 esto va a ser igual 100
menos 81 de 19 entre 6.3 va a ser un
valor ligeramente mayor que 3 y en el
próximo problema veremos qué implica eso
en términos de probabilidad de que
ocurra por lo pronto vamos a calcular el
valor de z que sería 19 entre 6.3 y esto
nos da tres puntos 01 de hecho 3.0 2 y
redondeamos el más cercano a 3.02 así
que el puntaje set es 3.02 o una
calificación de 100 está a 3.02
desviaciones estándar arriba de la media
así que recuerda aquí tenemos la media
una media de 81 aquí tenemos una
desviación estándar arriba de la media 2
desviación está arriba la media 3
desviación estándar arriba la media está
por aquí
aquí estamos ligeramente arriba de 3
23.02 aquí es donde tendríamos ubicado
una calificación de 100 y puedes ver que
la probabilidad que es esta altura es
muy muy baja es lo que nos dice la
gráfica de hecho no es tan solo muy baja
la probabilidad de obtener un valor
mayor que esto porque como ya sabemos en
una función densidad de probabilidad si
esto fuera continua no discreta al
problema obtener exactamente eso es cero
pero dado que son calificaciones de una
prueba sabemos que de hecho es una
función de probabilidad discreta pero al
ver donde estamos ubicados en la curva
de campana la probable a obtener un
valor mayor que este es muy baja en fin
espero que te haya quedado claro cómo
obtener puntaje z lo cual es un proceso
matemático bastante sencillo en el
próximo vídeo interpretaremos un poco
más puntaje 7 probabilidades